après 136 heures et 46 minutes de débat
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté le projet
de loi ouvrant le mariage au couple de
personnes de même sexe
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres mesdames
messieurs les députés je dois avouer que
je suis submerger par l'émotion nous
savons donc nous n'avons rien noté à
personne et qu'au contraire par ce texte
de loi nous avons reconnu les droits de
nos concitoyens dans la citoyenneté
sournoisement contestée et nous avons
ouvert des droits à tous les autres
couples c'est donc incontestablement un
texte généreux que vous avez voté
aujourd'hui et nous vous en savons
définitivement gris
nous savons aussi qu'il ne faut parler à
celles et ceux qui ont été blessés c'est
Jour Dernier par des mots par des gestes
par des actes leur dire que ils sont
pleinement de cette société et que nous
savons que la responsabilité de la
puissance publique c'est de lutter
contre les discriminations c'est une
exigence du pacte républicain et lutter
contre les discriminations c'est
évidemment ouvrir à tous les citoyens
les dispositifs de droits communs ainsi
que les plus belles institutions de la
République nous vont dire en particulier
aux adolescentes aux adolescents de ce
pays qui ont été blessés qui ont été
désemparés ces derniers jours qui ont
été dans un désarroi profond immense qui
ont découvert une société où une
sublimation des égoïsmes permettaient à
certains de protester bruyamment contre
les droits des autres nous voulons leur
dire simplement qu'ils sont dans leur
singularité et dans leur place dans la
société que nous les reconnaissons dans
leur place dans la société avec leur
mystère avec leurs talents avec leurs
défaut leur qualité leur fragilité que
c'est ça la singularité de chacune
chacun d'entre nous indépendamment même
de toutes les sciences sexuelles chacune
chacun d'entre nous est singulier et
c'est la force de la société et c'est
même la condition de la société c'est la
condition de la relation dans la société
alors nous leur disons si vous êtes pris
de désespérance balayez tout cela ce
sont des paroles qui vont s'envoler
rester avec nous et garder la tête haute
vous n'avez rien à vous reprocher nous
le disons haut et clair avoir puissante
parce que comme disait Nietzsche les
vérités tuent celle que l'on tait
deviennent vénéneuses merci à vous tous
[Applaudissements]